[Musique]
pourvu de précigné accès mais bonjour
axel bonjour nous commençons par
libération qui barre sa une d'un mot
liberté au bouddha en ukrainien la
guerre racontée par les journalistes qui
la vivent en première ligne libération
ouvre ses pages à nv un média fondée en
2014 après la révolution de la place
maïdan le rédacteur en chef un de nvi
explique que certains de ses
journalistes se sont engagés dans
l'armée que le site internet a été visé
par des pirates russes que les rentrées
publicitaires se sont taries et ils font
appel aux dons internationaux pour
continuer à informer à couvrir la guerre
alors je suis allé voir le site internet
de nv publié en trois langues et il fait
notamment aujourd'hui à ses gros titres
sur l'incendié survenu durant la nuit
dans la principale centrale nucléaire du
pays et même d'europe en termes de
capacité incendies provoqués par les
bombardements russes est un il a été
éteint tous les réacteurs sont intactes
assure nv élevé qui tentent d'informer
en ukraine mais en russie c'est
compliqué aussi la censure veille
commerçante journal économique russe de
renom et qui bénéficiait d'une certaine
liberté s'en fait l'écho vous le voyez
ici et vous devinez malgré l'écriture
cyrillique la bbc ou d'autres je vais le
voir leur site compliqué c'est compliqué
d'y accéder lire c'est notamment radio
moscou dont l'accès a été restreint et
parfois axel de simples dessins en dise
plus que les mots oui le kiff post
journal ukrainien qui avait failli
disparaître cet automne publie ce dessin
on représente souvent on voit souvent le
président poutine sur une table tout
seul et bien la table prend la forme
d'un cercueil autre journal ukrainien la
pravda publié des dessins d'enfants
plongé dans la guerre voilà vous les
deux vidéos vous les voyez ces dessins
qui à eux seuls aussi montre la cruauté
de la guerre et avec une question où est
ce que tout cela va-t-il s'arrêter selon
le guardian à poutine fait craindre que
le pire est à venir en ukraine avec pour
illustrer cette une photo d'un père
pleurant son fils photos prises dans une
maternité de mariupol maternité qui a
été transformé en hôpital de campagne
le daily mail interpelle poutine qui
débarrassera le monde de ce fou furieux
vi rhône thing made man talk to me parle
moi ça c'est dans le daily mirror car
pendant ce temps là le président
ukrainien
volodimir zelensky demande un tête à
tête avec poutine affirmant qu'il n'y a
pas d'autre moyen que de parler avec
poutine si l'on veut arrêter la guerre
notre actualitté ce matin que vous avez
choisi de traiter dans votre revue de
presse en même temps ne pouvait pas y
couper c'est la déclaration de
candidature d' emmanuel macron essais
partout avec cette lettre que vous voyez
ici qui a été reproduite dans plusieurs
journaux régionaux puisque le chef de
l'état a attendu le dernier jour du
calendrier électoral pour annoncer qu'il
était candidat à sa succession pour midi
libre c'est macron la saison 2 le
premier tour a lieu dans 38 jours et
vous voyez midi libre la manchette de
midi libre est aux couleurs de l'ukraine
parce que c'est impossible de se
détacher de cette actualité ukrainienne
d'ailleurs entre virus le corps d'un
virus et la guerre macron se déclare
enfin lasser l'opinion sur la forme le
président met ses pas dans ceux de
françois mitterrand et de jacques chirac
écrit l'opinion pour sa déclaration de
candidature privilégiant les cris et la
presse régionale puisque je vous le
disais c'est la presse régionale qui a
publié sa lettre de candidature sur le
fond il reprend ces mantras de 2017 il
laisse toutefois entrevoir un changement
de méthode s'il est réélu en tout cas
d'après le parisien un premier
déplacement est prévu lundi en ile de
france et un meeting aura lieu à
marseille le week-end du 12 mars donc
dans une semaine et puis regardez aussi
ce dessin du jour dans l'humanité
puisqu'il y avait aussi l'annoncé d'un
nouvel allègement des mesures sanitaires
et on voit un monsieur qui lie à cette
fois ça sent vraiment la fin mais c'est
plutôt la fin du monde est fou terminer
un mot des jeux paralympiques d'hiver
oui puisque il débute aujourd'hui
cérémonie d'ouverture à pékin là c'est
le china daily où on voit cet athlète
handicapé qui va faire du surf et le
snowboard le para snowboard en dix
autres et photos publiées par le china
daily je voulais vous montrer pour
illustrer ces jeux ce sont deux
volontaires qui change qui échangent les
mascottes il y avait la mascotte de binh
thuan dwayne le panda qui a fait fureur
pendant les jeux olympiques à les
changer par choix et rendent rhône qui
illustre vous savez c'est lanterne rouge
traditionnelle chinoise et c'est donc un
show and run run qui succède au panda
bing douanes douanes pour ces jeux
paralympiques merci beaucoup axel